[Music]
zeki decides to go on a trek
in the interiors of a dense forest
but his wealth land trekking trip didn't
last for long
as he's captured by the locals in that
area
is there any chance for zeki to break
out from the hands of these local people
yes there is a slim chance of escape
the locals follow a traditional law they
put the captives in prison which is
protected with
a padlock and that's what they do with
zeki as well
to escape the captives need to solve a
puzzle
and find the right combination of digits
in the padlock
which will open the door there is a
small twist to the story
the captives must be able to get the
code within the stipulated time
if successful they can walk towards
freedom
if not they are stranded there for their
lifetime
just like zeki the locals are smart too
they do not provide an easy puzzle
they provide the captives with five
jumbled combinations of eight different
digits
in sets of three and they also give them
clues
one for each set with this information
the captives need to find the three
digits in the correct order
which will open the padlock and set them
free
zeki takes a look at the clues and
within minutes
solves it and gains his freedom
how would you solve this if you were in
his place
can you use the clues and try finding
the three-digit code to open the door
now let me ask you a follow-up question
too
can you find the three-digit code using
just four of these five clues
is it possible or not give it a try
again
hey this is ganesh here from don't
memorize before we get to the solution
of this riddle
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and hit the bell icon
so that you never miss a video from us
okay back to where we left off
there are many ways to solve this as our
brain normally asks us to solve problems
serially here's some advice it's
always preferable to have a glance at
all the clues first
and then proceed with the best possible
one
so after we glance through all we should
realize
that the master clue among all is clue
number two
which says nothing is correct
why am i calling this the master clue it
tells us
that none of these three digits is a
part of the three digit code
and look at all the other ones written
they all talk about
correct digits as 5
3 and 0 can never be correct
we can strike them out from all the
combinations here
so this clue makes our work a lot more
easier
now let's move serially clue after clue
the first clue says one digit is correct
and well placed will this give us any of
the digits in the three-digit code
not really this tells us that either
four is in the correct place
or eight is in the correct place but
nothing concrete yet
it tells us that one of these two is a
digit of the three-digit code
there's nothing else we can deduce from
this clue
now look at clue number three it says
that
two digits are correct but in the wrong
place
this looks interesting based on the
second clue
digit 5 is already struck out from the
list
this implies that two of the correct
digits in the three digit code
are 1 and 7. now what about their
placement
it says that they are wrongly placed so
now we know that digit 1 is not in the
first position
and digit 7 is not in the third position
so let's quickly review what all we've
concluded
we know that either four is in the
second position or
eight is in the third position only
one of these two can be correct we also
know
that digits one and seven are two of the
digits of the three-digit code
and one is definitely not in the first
position
and seven is definitely not in the third
by combining these two clues we can also
say
that the three digits are one seven and
one of the two digits
for an eight so let's cancel out
all the other possible digits from our
clue so we can cancel
six from the fourth and the fifth clue
in such problems elimination is the key
the more you eliminate with certainty
the easier your problem gets
so let's move ahead with the next clue
one digit is correct but in the wrong
place zero and six are already
eliminated from the list
and the only digit remaining is eight
so we get the third digit of the code
and that is
eight as it's wrongly placed
we know that eight is not in the first
position in the three-digit code
so the three digits in the code are one
seven
and eight so let's eliminate the other
digits from all the clues
we eliminate four from the first clue
and the fifth clue
now let's get back to the first clue it
says
that one digit is correct and well
placed
the only digit remaining is 8. the digit
8 is correct
and well placed so in our three digit
code
the third position will be occupied by
the digit 8.
can you find the digits in the first and
the second positions now
we can jump to the third clue again it
says
that the digits 1 and 7 are a part of
the three digit code
it also tells us that one is not in the
first position
and seven is not in the third position
what can we deduce now if one is not in
the first position
where can it be as the third position is
occupied by the digit eight
the digit one has to be in the second
position
as we know that the three digits are one
seven and eight
we can say that seven has to be present
in the first position
we have a three digit code now it's
seven
one eight and we didn't even use the
fifth clue
so the code to open the padlock is seven
one eight the correct approach for such
problems
is look at the clue and eliminate after
you've understood it
before signing off would you like to try
solving
another similar problem here are your
set of clues
can you solve it to find the three-digit
code
leave your answers in the comment
section below and also tell us
if you used all the clues